[Music]
reject nation Greg Alva here John is me
if you guys saw our initial reactions on
Tomb Raider but go watch it go watch it
when it comes out
save date guys we're gonna check out a
highly requested video mean tweets music
edition number four in the David Gandy
[Music]
James he looks like stop because walk
into a and is that he looks like a
[Music]
[Laughter]
shampoo on my pubes and now my peers
looks like Steve Aoki
Waterfalls by TLC has to be the worst
song about waterfalls ever
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'd rather be homeless than watch two
cats bang in an alley gonna go to a
Ludacris concert I will be is if a
flaccid penis could kind of sing no this
is riddled with mistakes my horn is okay
good night everyone
[Laughter]
my parents would force me to listen to
if I were white and you're listening to
the pressure mode reached into your
vagina and pull your balls back more
challenge in my toilet this morning in
green day has ever had Green Day sucks
I'm glad that you're thinking about us
while you're taking dumps I'm doing
something right well think about you
[Applause]
thanks thank you do they just like
compiled the like if you come in as a
musical guest or something do they just
say like hey sit down really quick read
a couple tweets compile these yeah how
do they as summer they all have come and
they all come in in one day we got a
whole I think the musical guys are
better sports about it than some of the
actors and stuff actually they seem like
they really just you had a laugh about
it some a lot of times these actors
celebrities most of them laugh but a lot
of them seem like yeah I see a lot of
these a lot of these guys are sort of
laughing it off more readily yeah like
you know there were a couple dead pans
but even the dead pans felt like they
were in good fun yeah exactly man I
think these mean tweets are a great
thing it's just ever my it's it's
healthy specially for like you know us
we're not like the crazy popular stage
well we're still in the phase where like
most of these people can go yes this
tweet kind of hurts but look at all the
success we look at all the
world we've traveled and whatnot we're
in the we're in the YouTube phase of
five hundred twenty thousand followers
and average video view count of five to
twenty killing the game kill him a game
right now killing the game I want a
reaction survive death surviving off the
few videos a month that you agree yeah
this is a fun ass video and we wanted to
shout out David Gandy for this one
because David Gandy we know you're
heavily into music my friend you were
two messaging me on patreon saying to us
that you have Meghan Trainor one person
Megan listen to if I was white David you
were saying how you know you might want
to come meet up with us when we're
watching infinity war maybe you want to
go to the IMAX time well dude you live
in California and I know you're like a
few hours away from us in California but
if you want to come down to SoCal and
meet up with us I got a great gas
station we can meet at which has a
awesome restroom in there and a carved
out hole where I ventilation D yeah
we'll go with that we'll go with that
I'll go with that
or your thing well yeah my thing is used
for ventilation purposes oh yeah of
course of course I know how you like air
flow I know you're really into that
David David Gandy seems like you would
like it tense before movie experience
nothing makes me feel better than to put
my mouth yeah by the way it wasn't you I
was implying dude it is me on a
ventilation hole glory be glory glory to
the highest ventilation yeah you know
cuz cuz bathroom stalls again there are
all kinds of smells and things going on
in there you need some place to let the
fresh air and other foreign objects in I
thought I would do a music related
shout-out but instead you're getting
this gas station one which is even
better it's even honestly it's it's more
creative I write my mean tweets on that
gas stations bathroom wall - so while
I'm getting ventilation while I'm
putting my hands through the hole but
that's different that's just ashes me
you know that's just my extracurricular
stuff that's not what the hole is
actually for subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified every time where vids is up
catch you on the flip